>> When I was looking up center
for artificial
intelligence in society,
one of the first thing
that struck
me is that it's a group of
department of computer science
working with the department
of social work.
In my knowledge, you can't
get computer science
to work with computer
engineering and so
this is really
interesting that there
is an interdisciplinary effort
in University of
Southern California that there's
a vision to understand that
this kind of work happens
when we work together.
We have today three folks who
will be presenting
Milind, Eric Rice,
and Bistra Dilkina but we also
have Jordan Davis and
Phebe Vayanos who are
also faculty at- Sze Suen and
Brian as well, I'm sorry.
>> Well, thank you.
This is so exciting.
We've been working on
trying to put this
together in collaboration with
Microsoft Research and it's
absolutely fantastic that this
has come together we may excited.
My name is Milind Tambe
and along with me here as
it was just mentioned we have
Eric Rice and Bistra Bilkina
who'll jointly give
this presentation.
I should start my clock because
I want to be done
in 10 minutes and
then Eric and Bistra
will takeover and they'll
speak for 10 minutes each.
Phebe Vayanos, Sze, and
Jordan and Bryan Wilder
are students so together this
represents bulk of
the center's faculty.
So, just to very
quickly tell you about
our center VR this USC Center
for AI in Society or CAIS,
it's an interdisciplinary center
that six key faculty are
all present here today.
There's 24 PhD students
you only got one here but
the remaining ones are back there
and we'll talk to them later.
Our focus is AI for
societal problems and
we are very keen on
starting projects in India.
To show our keenness
I wanted to show
two slides. No politics.
So, we were really thrilled to
be in the audience when
honorable Prime Minister
talked about AI for
societal benefits
in Mumbai and so very inspiring.
Then, this was in
February and then in
June when honorable External
Affairs Minister held
a roundtable meeting on
artificial intelligence and there
too we were honored to be
invited and that's me you can
see hiding behind in the back.
Again, we talked about how
AI could be used for
societal benefits.
So, we're very keen on
starting projects here.
Just to give you
a flavour for the kinds
of projects that we
have done at USC,
our focus has been on
three areas public safety
and security,
public health and conservation
and I'll give
a general overview and
then Eric will talk
in depth about
public health and Bistra
about conservation.
So, the basic problem we
focus on is how to optimize
our limited intervention
resources using
AI in order to solve
societal problems.
So, let's take public health,
Eric will discuss this in
more depth but give
you a concrete example
HIV AIDS is a big problem with
the homeless population
in Los Angeles.
How to spread information about
HIV amongst the homeless youth.
We can't talk to everybody,
there're 6,000 homeless youth.
So, we have to identify
key peer leaders who
will spread information.
We show that AI
techniques are far more
effective in finding
this peer leaders to
spread information compared to
traditional methods
and this we've
done with pilot test
on the ground so
these are always things
that we test out.
But can we try this out for
TB prevention and for other
kinds of health challenges?
For conservation, we've been
working a lot in Uganda for
the past several years for
the Uganda Wildlife Authority
to protect endangered wildlife.
Here, with machine learning
we predict that poachers will
attack with traps or snares and
remove them before
they kill animals.
We've done this for
past several years,
a lot of snares
have been removed,
animals hopefully
have been saved,
and with drones getting
infrared video,
detecting poachers and animals on
the fly from these infrared video
so that they can be stopped.
Bistra will discuss this
in much more depth.
We have also a lot of
interesting public safety
and security counter terrorism.
We've worked a lot with
government agencies,
coast guard, the Transportation
Security Administration.
Large number of
targets to protect,
where and when to patrol,
where and when to put security
checkpoints, and so forth.
This is not the focus
of this workshop,
I'm not going to
talk about it but
these the software that's
actually in use for
over a decade by these
agencies just to
tell you that we're
very interested in
getting the software
deployed and in use.
This is now spreading
to other countries like
Israel and Argentina
and so forth.
So, I wanted to talk a little
bit about the fact when
we solve problems we firmly
believe in interdisciplinary
partnerships.
So, to that end we've really
worked with the Coast Guard
patrolling with them
on their Coast Guard ports
in New York or patrolled in
the forests of Malaysia with
the wildlife
conservation agencies.
Eric has spent
15 years working with
homeless populations in
Los Angeles and so on.
So, when we start solving
problems we always start with
immersing ourselves in the
domain and trying to get data.
This is not a situation where
data is ready made available.
We are very interested
in trying to identify,
get the right data.
Following that of
course the next step
is predictive analytics that is,
given the data can we predict
which cases may be high risk
which may be low-risk?
Many AI systems stop
there just predicting
high and low risk cases but we at
our center are interested
in doing more.
With limited intervention
resources can
we go beyond and do
prescriptive analytics?
That is where to take our
limited resources and
place them so that we
get the highest benefit
not just identify
high and low risk but
which cases should we
take on given our
limited resources.
Now many AI systems will stop
there but our center
we really are very
interested in going
one step beyond and
testing this prescription in
the field and understanding
where we have gone right and
wrong so that this can then
inform our data collection.
Very quickly just
as an example in
the wildlife conservation domain
data collection would be,
where are the snares
place based on
that predictive
analytics would say,
where are the high-risk
areas in the park?
Where are the low risk
Prescriptive analytics would say,
where should you patrol given
that you know high and
low risk areas?
Finally testing in the field
which I would send
out the patrollers,
get them to patrol, do we
get the results that
we want or not?
If we don't then change
our model or algorithm.
So, as I said all of
the cases that I talked
about are deployed,
tested we're very interested
in actually testing things in
the field and not
just writing papers
and so this is very,
very important to our center.
I just wanted to talk about
a few projects that we have in
my last four minutes or so that
may inform you about some of
the ongoing efforts
at our center.
Eric and Bistra will
talk more of course.
So, for example AI can
help in obesity
prevention efforts.
This is an idea of
how could we optimize
public outreach efforts
within limited budgets,
can we help improve
TB treatment by predicting
defaulters and I
understand Amid may
have discussed some of
the work that's going
on in this context.
But let me take on this
childhood obesity prevention.
So, this is in
the United States not
a very large problem
childhood obesity.
So, in Antelope Valley which is
North of Los Angeles where
our university is located,
there's a low-resource
community where
only 10 percent of kids are
perceived by their
parents to be healthy.
So, we're working with
our school of medicine
to try to see if we can
prevent childhood obesity.
So, this is done because
the basic idea is trying
to get peers to
influence parents to get
children to eat healthy.
In other words, get
mothers to cook together
healthy food but
which mothers should cook
together because that's the wave
we'll determine health outcomes.
So, essentially if
you look at it from
a graph each of
these nodes you could
imagine is a mother,
the red node is the mother
whose children are unhealthy.
So, who do we pair
this mother with in
order to get the health
outcomes we want?
So, should we get
this one to connect with
this one and then maybe drop
a connection to this other one
because that's not
a healthy relationship of one
this kind of a group
and so forth?
So, those are the
questions we can solve.
This is work that's going on in
Antelope Valley this is
something that we're very
interested in deploying.
Another project that's
also ongoing is worth
when urban peak business in
Denver a homeless shelter.
Here, we have a social
network of youth who
are addicted, who
abuse substances.
These are shown by the red nodes,
the black nodes are ones who are
healthy and the question then
becomes can we create groups so
that we reduce substance abuse?
So, can you partition
the graph creating
groups where
healthy outcome prevails
because the peers can
influence this red node
because they have been cut
off from these other red node
in order to change
their behaviour?
So, these things
trying to figure out
which partitions can
perform better so
that we avoid deviancy
training because if you
incorrectly create partitions
then actually
addiction increases.
So we want to reduce
my addiction by
creating the right kinds
of partitions.
A third challenge that we've
recently taken on is
trying to look at
infectious diseases.
In India, we know there's
half a million deaths due to TB.
How to get more patients
into treatment.
So, there's outreach effort,
and some of you may know
a whole lot more about this,
but this is what we
understand that there are
different outreach efforts,
the question is,
this different outreach efforts
reach different segments
of the population,
different geographical
areas, who to target,
how to spread our limited budget.
So, we've constructed
a multi-agent model
for disease spread and
an AI algorithm that based on
realistic data can do
an experimental evaluation
based on this.
We show that our models can do
better than what has
been done at status quo.
Now clearly, this is done
as a simulation exercise
based on realistic data
that we can get hold off,
but the basic point is,
if you have limited resources,
how to invest them
in order to get
the right kinds of outcomes
based on whatever data we have.
So, that's the type of
work that we can do.
So, I'll end here
by saying there is
a tremendous potential for use of
AI for societal benefits.
We are very interested in
applications here of
your work Africa,
in South America, and
we're really keen on
pushing this forward.
So, it's 10 minutes and I'm
going to hand this over
to Eric to start his 10 minutes.
>> I'm really excited
to be here as well.
This is my opportunity to talk
about two projects that are
really near and dear to my heart,
which are working with
homeless teenagers.
So, I've been working with
homeless teenagers and
young adults for the last
15 years in Los Angeles,
and I'm going to talk
about one project that's
on HIV prevention and another
project that's on housing.
The point of this
is really to give,
especially the folks who are in
the NGO space in this room,
a sense of how we approach
our work and also
some of the kinds
of problems that
we can tackle with technologies
that maybe are things that you
haven't thought about before.
So, the first thing that
I want to mention and
Jordan Davis here is with me as
well from the School of
Social Work is that,
social work researchers,
we're very invested in
very intimate partnerships with
non-government organizations
and government organizations.
So, Jordan and I have
actually both done
intervention work,
small-group work with,
in his case youth
who've been in substance
abuse treatment programs,
in my case with
homeless teenagers and so,
we don't just do research work,
but we actually do work out in
the world that
social service providers do.
We do it hand-in-hand with them.
So, this is actually
a picture of me actually
interacting with a young person
out in the field.
This is something that
happens on a regular basis.
The issue is that,
there are 4.2 million
homeless youth in
the United States each year.
There's 300 million citizens
of the United States.
We're not nearly as
large as you all are,
but homelessness
is a big problem.
What this has suggested
recently is that
almost one in 10 teenagers
between the ages of
13 and 24 will experience
homelessness every year.
So, this is becoming
an increasingly large problem
as the class divide becomes
larger in the United States.
HIV prevalence is
nearly 10 percent
amongst this group of people.
So, we really need
to think about,
how can we target
this very large group of people
who need HIV prevention work?
So, our community partners in
this context are three different
drop-in centers
where homeless youth
can go and access services.
One is Safe Place for Youth,
another is My Friend's Place,
another is the Los
Angeles LGBT center,
where we've done this work.
These are partner
organizations that
I've been working with
for about 15 years.
What we're trying to
do in this context
is a peer-led intervention.
So, the idea is,
we don't have enough
resources to do
HIV prevention work with
every single homeless
youth in the city.
But we can find strategic folks
who are the right people,
who can be our advocates,
who we can train to go and do
health outreach work
in their community.
The complexity of this,
however is that
the social networks
of these homeless
youth even within
one of these centers are
these dizzying arrays.
So, what we're stuck with is
a problem that I
like to think of as
very keen to the problem
that Google Maps solves.
So, we're trying to
do optimal planning,
and what we have is a network,
where there's a lot of noise.
There's a lot of uncertainty.
We might not know exactly
who's connected to whom,
people might get
into fights with one
another and stop being
friends with one another.
So, this is a moving target.
Much like traffic in
a city is a moving target.
But like with Google
maps where you
want a specific solution,
we want a specific solution
to who should we pick is
this small group of
young people that we
can train to do this activity.
So, we developed algorithms that
parse the community
into smaller sections,
find specific key leaders.
I'm going to spare
you all of the math,
just show you pictures today,
and what's exciting
about this is that,
when we compare these systems to
the standard ways in which
public health and social work
have done this in the past,
what we see here is that,
the AI driven solutions far
outperform the usual status quo
Public Health Solutions,
and we're looking at, in
these networks we're seeing
about 70 percent of
the target youth were getting
messages about
HIV prevention versus
only about 27 percent
in the standard group.
Then, when we're thinking about
people going out and
getting HIV testing,
which is one of the important
things you need to do
if you're going to
link people into
antiretroviral drugs,
is that we see again,
a big difference here in terms of
those who were reached
by our messaging.
We had about almost
30 to 40 percent of
those young people went and got
an HIV test and so therefore,
could start to get engaged in
treatment if they needed it,
versus the standard
public health,
arm of this field
deployment where we
actually had no new testers
in that space.
So, we see this not as
a perfect solution,
but when Milton was putting
out this pathway of
going from collecting data
with community partners,
then doing predictive analytics,
and then doing
prescriptive analytics
and then doing field tests,
this is one example of a project
that we've been invested
in for several years
and we're actually
currently right
now just about to finish
out a trial where
we've enrolled nearly a
thousand homeless young people
over the last year and
a half into this program.
One last thing that I'll mention
is that what seems to be of
great benefit of some of
these AI programs is that,
in an age in which
especially young people are
very excited about technology,
these are two young men who
were picked by our algorithms
to become peer leaders and
they felt very empowered
by this entire experience,
and they actually started
to do much better,
and actually both
of these young men
ended up getting jobs and housing
within the two years
after this initial program
went forward.
So, the other program that
I want to talk about is a
little bit earlier
in its development.
This is something that
I've been working very
closely with Phebe Vayanos
who's not going to get
a chance to stand up
and speak but I'm going
to get to actually speak for her
which is not entirely fair
but here we are
working on housing.
So, I've been working with
governmental organizations and
non-governmental organizations
in the United States
around housing issues for
the last five or six years.
This has been something
that's a relatively
more recent body of my work,
but again the issue
is one of scarcity.
So, we have this huge number
of young people who are on
the streets and we don't have
nearly enough resources
to give them.
The United States is
this very wealthy country with
a very broken social
welfare system.
So, we are working with
the Los Angeles Housing
Service Authority.
This is the governmental
organization
in Los Angeles that is
both the city and
the county in which were
located and they provide
most of the housing resources
for homeless youth.
So, they're our partner in
this particular effort and what
we're trying to do here is
something that is
very much like Uber.
So, what the idea is,
is that we have a small number
of houses that are
available at any one time,
we've got a large
number of people
that are waiting for housing.
So, how do we match
just like Uber would
match drivers to riders
through this traffic?
How do we match the right people
to the right housing resources,
so that we can do two things?
We can optimize the success
of those housing resources
because since there's
so few we don't want
to waste any precious resource,
but the other idea is
that we want to make
sure that people
are treated fairly.
So, there's a lot of
discussion right now in
the ethical area of AI
around bias and algorithms,
and that if you just train
systems that are built on
former datasets that
may have a lot of
implicit bias in them you will
just reproduce these biases.
So, what we really want
to do in this is we
want to improve on two things,
fairness as well as
the actual efficiency.
So, the current system for
housing allocation
is very simplistic.
What you get is, young people are
asked about 50 questions
and from these 50
questions they're
assigned a score that ranges
from one to 17 and depending
on whether they score eight
or higher they get
really good services,
if they score four to seven
they get rental subsidies,
and if they score less than
four they get nothing.
We've approached
this in the way that
Mill described and I guess
this is not showing up so well.
So, this says machine-learning
about prediction and then this is
going to be policies
that are prescriptive.
But what we really
want to do with
these policies is we want to
make sure that they're
interpretable, right?
This simplistic
scoring mechanism,
although it's maybe not
the most effective thing
in the world
which I'll show you in a minute.
It least is something that
people can understand.
So, we want to make sure
that the AI that we build
in these social
service contexts is
one that where people can
explain to their clients
that they're working with.
Why they are or are not
eligible for services?
We can't just deny
people housing and
say well the computer says
you don't get housing.
So, what we're interested in is
optimizing our success like
Uber but we also want to make
sure that we avoid
discrimination.
One of the big issues
in the United States
is racial discrimination.
So, these are
Hispanic and black youth,
these are traditionally
populations that have suffered
a lot of discrimination and
marginalization in
the United States.
This I want you to
just only focus
in on the top and
the bottom here.
That I don't have enough time
to explain everything in
between but the top
is the current system
as it exists and what you
see here is that the white
youth that are purple,
they're benefiting
at much higher rates
than the Hispanic
and the black youth.
Freebies algorithm is
able to change this.
So, this is a
computational experiment
where we're doing
some prescriptive analytics
and we're saying
if we changed who
we gave the housing
interventions to,
so we didn't just do
this simplistic system
that is currently in place.
We can greatly reduce by
looking at the individual
characteristics of
these young people,
we could greatly reduce
the inequalities here and
what's even more exciting
again focus on the top and
the bottom is that
you can see this is
the overall successful number
of outcomes in
the system as a whole,
and what we're able to do
is we're able to create
a bump of about 10 percent
in this system,
which is actually
a really big deal.
This ends up being thousands of
people when you're talking
about the scale of
homelessness that you have in
Los Angeles where we've got
50,000 people on the streets
on any given night.
So with that, I will turn
things over to Bistra
who's also going to talk
to you about some of
the implications that
we've had recently.
>> CAIS also had a lot
of projects that
involve using AI for
wildlife conservation.
As you all know there's been
a dramatic decline in
the populations of many species,
many of them in dangers
like tigers and elephants,
as well as rhinos
and and giraffes.
Unfortunately, a lot of
this decline is also
due to poaching for
illegal wildlife trade.
So, CAIS over the last four
to five years has actually
partnered with several
NGO's such as WCS,
WWF and Panthera to try
to help them to develop
AI based tools to
make the anti-poaching efforts
more effective.
In the process we have
developed a tool called
PAWS that helps them
deploy patrolling efforts in
protected areas to catch
poacher in the act.
In fact, PAWS as I will show you
later has become
so successful that
now in the last
five months we have
partnered with SMART
which is a consortium
which includes this three
organizations as well
as many more and SMART has a tool
which helps many protected areas
record their data in terms
of patrolling effort
and detect illegal activity
and build reports for
those protected areas.
Now SMART is trying to
incorporate our AI based tools
to actually provide them
analytics and planning component
that will let them have
more effective deployment in
the field and therefore
we will allow us to
reach more than 600 parks
in which SMART is
currently used over
more than 55 countries.
So, the way that PAWS works
is actually again as
Mill mentioned earlier,
starting from raw data
collected over
the years in this parks
that includes
the patrolling as well as
the detections of
illegal activity,
combining it with additional
information such as GS,
information across
the park, on the roads,
rivers, the park boundaries,
land cover et cetera.
And using that data to
build a predictive model of
where we expect there
to be the highest risk
of poaching given
the particular time
of the year and
the particular characteristics
of a grid cell in the park.
Okay? And together with
this predictive model,
then we are actually able
to help them with also with
the prescriptive part saying with
the limited resources of
park rangers they have,
where should they send them
at any particular time.
So, this is combining
things like machine
learning together with
optimization and game theory.
So, as I mentioned,
we have worked on this over
an extended period of time.
In particular, we have worked
closely with two parks in Uganda,
Queen Elizabeth and
Murchison Falls.
So, using historic data
from those two parks,
we have developed
the progressively more
and more accurate
machine learning models
for the poaching risk,
achieving accuracy of 0.86
in our best current model.
But we don't stop there.
Okay. That's
our accuracy in the lab.
The most important thing
is to actually see whether
these models really
work in the field.
So, we went a step further,
and actually had
fueled best when both
parks over more between
six and nine months
where we generated
patrolled areas
where they had not
previously patrolled.
Some of which areas
were predicted to be
high risk and some low risk
based on our models,
and later in Murchison Falls
refined that to
even high medium and
low risk without
telling the rangers,
which is which they patrol
from six to nine months,
and at the end of
the day, we just looked
at the data of what happened.
What we discovered that in fact,
the areas where our model
was predicting high risk,
they were able to find
many more snares per patrol
effort that is spent there.
So, in fact, it was extremely
accurate in allocating
resources more effectively
than just guessing at random.
So, with this
predictive modeling,
we can now that we
also know it works in
the field were also
able to tell them more
strategically of how exactly
to send their ranges to
patrol and incorporate important
on the ground constraints,
such as where other ranges
where should they start from,
how much can they walk at
most in any given day, right?
So, with the predictive model
and in this constraint,
our optimization
game theoretic model
is able to generate
maps like that,
which says exactly where to
walk and how much effort to
spend in each grid cell
depending on the
characteristics of that,
and the corresponding
prediction of
how likely they are to detect
approaching activity there.
So, we're really
excited about in fact,
going to the deployment stage,
working with smart,
and really getting
the system out in the world.
In addition to rangers,
one additional resource that
more and more protected areas
are thinking about is
the use of UAVs in order to
augment the patrolling of humans,
NGO with which they're working on
this, Cold Air Shepherd,
which is using UAVs driven
in advance during the night,
and sending those drones to
actually patrol in
real-time for poachers,
and having people sit,
and trying to look
at the videos in
real-time to detect
poachers called
rangers if something is
suspicious, and
respond effectively.
Unfortunately, looking
at these videos is
extremely difficult and tiring,
and so their current setup
is not really scalable.
So, they came to us and trying to
help them to build
a more effective system.
So, as you can see,
this black and white videos
during the night with
an infrared camera are extremely
difficult to interpret.
They are very low-resolution,
the objects we are trying to
detect that extremely small.
The camera is moving,
there's other things like
vegetation and
reflection that look
exactly like
the little specks that
might be poachers, right?
So, it's extremely hard problem.
So, we built a system are
based on deep learning,
which somehow the slides
are messed up.
A system based on
deep learning to predict,
to interpret these videos.
Unfortunately, labeling
the videos is extremely time
consuming and so we
have a limited amount
of training data,
but we partnered with
Microsoft in there
video engine called
AirSim to actually
create a version of it,
which simulates
the African savanna,
and poachers, and animals
in that African savanna.
So, we are able to gather with
also a model of a drone flying in
the simulation to generate
additional simulation data that
looks very much
like the real data.
So, together with the labeled
very non-cost effective labeled,
the real world data with
augmented simulated data,
we are able to, no,
I guess it's not going to show,
the result on the side.
To improve the accuracy
of our model,
both in the recall
and precision much
beyond their current system
that they're using in the field.
So, they're actually
currently testing it,
using it in their actual events,
and we also have
a Cloud-based implementation
of the system.
So, beyond anti-poaching efforts,
we also have several projects
related to conservation planning,
can informing decision-making,
makers in how to most
effectively uses
very limited dollars allocated to
conservation to generate
the best ecological impact.
So, one such problem
we know how to address
is how to inform
preserving landscape
connectivity for species.
So, as the habitat
gets more and more
fragmented because of roads,
urbanization, agriculture, etc.,
essentially species
cannot move from
one remnant of
habitat to another,
which really jeopardizes
their long-term persistence.
So, what we can do about this,
we can try to selectively,
try to intervene by for
example, building overpasses,
over route or underpasses or
protecting specific areas
from urbanization,
and essentially providing
wildlife corridors
for these animals
to move and preserve
their populations.
However, this is a very
difficult problem where you have
multiple opportunities with
different effects
and different costs,
which interact with each
other because essentially,
the combination of
all these interventions
changed the landscape
in terms of the best movement
pathways for these animals.
So, we've developed
an algorithm that allows for
us to produce such
intervention optimum plants.
So, we've tested this in
Western Montana where
a threatened species
called the wolverine has
several remaining populations
in the green parks,
but which are basically
disconnected because of
our high urbanization in
the remaining carriers and
the cost of intervention
is also very
expensive in across
most of the landscape.
So, with our method,
we are able to
generate a subset of
specific intervention
points here in
red, which essentially reroute,
and improve the
movement corridors for
these species from
the yellow ones
to the black ones that
are shown here, and help
hopefully the long-term
persistence of the species.
So, this was a brief overview,
but this basically just gives you
a sample of the kind
of methodologies
that we use in the
conservation space again,
leveraging machine
learning as well as
optimization and game
theory to help these NGOs.
So, thank you very much.